[Music]
another glorious morning
dad always says the pack stays together
that's my girl seat belt mode
now we're searching for a perfect place
to call
what the home is that it's the end of
the world
well that's it for me i'm glad it's you
chunky
isn't it strange how this food grows in
perfectly straight
oh genius
[Music]
i thought cave people died off years ago
we
happy meet you
thanks oh we are the betterments
better man emphasis on the better
hey girl another teenage girl yeah
a girl friend i've never
i don't know if cave people belong in a
modern world
what's your problem big guy this place
is changing everyone
die and we really need to limit
thunks window time not now douglas the
birds are on
in my day we didn't stare at birds we
fought them let me live my life
whoa what's that it's just a scar every
mark is an adventure
and my dad doesn't even know about this
one whoa
peanut toe you're not allowed outside
the wall
nope this farm is like your cave
you're just like me i feel like taking
chance
you see that wall yeah i want to jump in
yeah
we'll be back before anyone knows
you took dawn for a joyride the
betterment built the wall for a reason
that's not good
the only way to survive is if the pack
stays together
in such a dangerous world i worry about
my family
too what's that
kill circle
today is a good day to die
hey everyone you'll never guess what i
found out sorry honey
we thought you were a predator trying to
kill us no never apologize for an
effective kill circle
hold on stop you accessorize with a
sloth i accessorize with the sloth this
is built
mindset
you